can you say
why we know that black holes exist
right so it's an interesting
question because black holes were
considered a theoretical construct
and einstein even denied their existence
in 1939
but then in the 19 in the mid
1960s quasars were discovered these are
very bright
sources of light 100 times brighter than
their host galaxy
which are point-like at this at the
center of galaxies
and it was immediately suggested
uh by ed salpiter in the west
and by yakov zeldovich in the east
that these are black holes that accrete
gas collect gas from their host galaxy
that are being fed
with gas and they shine very brightly
because as the gas
uh falls towards the black holes uh just
like water
um you know running down the the sink
uh the gas swirls
and then rubs against itself and
heats up and shines very brightly
because it's very hot close to the black
hole
by viscous by viscosity it it
heats up uh and in in the case of black
holes it's the turbulence the
turbulent viscosity that causes it to
heat up so
um we get these very bright sources of
light just
from black holes that are supposed to be
dark you know nothing escapes from them
but
they create a violent environment where
gas moves close to the speed of light
light and therefore shines very brightly
much more than any other source in the
sky
and we can see these quasars all the way
to the edge of the universe
so we have evidence now that when the
universe was
you know about uh seven percent of its
present age you know
infant uh already back then you had
black holes of a billion
times the mass of the sun which is quite
remarkable you know it's like
finding giant babies in a nursery you
know like
how can these black holes grow so fast
you know less than a billion years after
the big bang
you already have a billion times the
mass of the sun in these black holes and
the answer is presumably there are very
quick
processes that build them up they they
they build quickly very quickly and so
we see those black holes
and that was found in the mid 1960s but
in 19
in sorry in 2015 exactly a hundred years
after einstein came up with his fear of
gravity
the ligo observatory detected
gravitational waves
and these are just ripples in space and
time so according to einstein's theory
the
the innovation the ingenuity of
einstein's theory of gravity
that was formulated in november 1915
was to say that space and time are not
rigid
you know they are they respond
to matter so for example if you have two
black holes
and they collide it's just like
a stone being thrown into this on a
surface of a pond
they generate waves disturbances in
space and time that propagate out at the
speed of light these are gravitational
waves
they create a space-time storm around
them and then the waves go
all the way through the universe and
reach us and if you have a sensitive
enough
detector like ligo you can detect these
waves and
so it was not just the message that we
received for the first time
gravitational waves
but it was the messenger so there are
two aspects to it one is the messenger
which is gravitational wave for the
first time were detected directly
and the second was the message which was
a collision of two black holes
because we could see the pattern of the
ripples in space and time
and it was fully consistent with the
prediction that schwarzsch had made for
how a black the space time around the
black hole is because when two black
holes
collide you can sort of map from the
message that you get you can
reconstruct what what really happened
and it's fully consistent
you